I wear makeup not because I feel like
I need it to be pretty or whatever,
I just use it because I like
to see what I can do with the hands.
I just think it’s a lot of fun
just to experiment.
Freedom to be creative
and see what I can do.
When I went out and about
before these hands
and I was just walking
around with my arms,
people would always stare at them.
They would come over to me
and ask what happened.
And I had to repeat
the same story like:
"I got a really bad disease called
meningitis septicaemia, nearly died."
And it's just a really
negative topic of conversation.
Whereas now with these hands,
when I go outside -
everyone who sees us
are excited by them.
Feel free to play
with her hands Maurine.
Can I?
Yeah, yeah look!
That’s great, that really is.
It's fabulous!
It's more like, "Woah how did you get
these hands? How do I get some?
They're amazing.
You're like a superhero."
You can do thumbs up
as well can't you?
Yeah.
Everyone's really excited by them,
rather than feeling sorry for me
all the time.
And I like that so much better.
There are muscle sensors inside
of the hands,
so you can actually control them
just by touching them.
The sensors are connected
to my muscles.
I squeeze my muscles
to close the hand.
I flex to open.
And then if I want to change the grip
then I can flex again.
They definitely help me to multitask
so I am now able to like,
pull a suitcase and hold
a hot chocolate and drink it.
Dad look I've been practicing with
the hands and I can do a fist.
Very nice!
Having these hands you have the
freedom to have your independence,
like you can do what you want without
having to rely on other people.
Look I've got... finger shadow.
Aww. Your own little shadow.
That’s cute.
I really hope that these hands
will be available on
National Health Service.
These hands are
£10,000 a pair I believe.
And that's a lot cheaper
than what we used to have.
You know what, it's so heart-warming
just watching her like, doing that.
This is what I mean, the simple
things that change your life.
Simple stuff like holding
her hand or...
telling she's got
little finger shadows.
It's so cute.
I feel like my determination
has got me to where I am today.
Impressive!
The main goal is like...
ultimate independence just like
anybody else with hands can have.
Because obviously I don’t want to
live with you forever, no offence.
But I want to move out
and have my own house
and I want to be able
to do everything
that anyone with hands can do.
So that’s the main goal in the long
run and I think we're definitely
not too far away from that.
I think it will make everyone,
not just amputees, feel better
if everyone just stopped
judging each other
and just live your life
without being judged.